it's easy to troll her and it's easy for
her to troll other men but we don't know
that story so if somebody from the
outside says who's Patrick David here's
a rich guy he's probably raised in a you
know I remember there was a time in the
third year the insurance company I was
paying comp more than my competitors
were a rumor started circulating saying
pass link to oil money and you know what
I did with that rumor I ran with it I
said you're right I have oil money I can
pay to count them on your campaign I
don't have oil money I worked out a 99
cent store in Inglewood by Great Western
Forum 15 years but I love that rumor so
I ran with it so if somebody doesn't
know your story great you can say what
you can say so if I face opposition I
tell them how much you know about me
tell me your story tell me about your
upbringing why did you come to the
conclusion of the opinions that you have
today tell me I remember when this
happened that okay great can I tell you
why I came to this conclusion yes here's
mine is it fair that we have different
reasons why we came to this conclusion
you got life changing experience like
that as well how about we respect each
other let me make my case to you you
make your case to me